ponctuel le sanctions économiques et la
résolution franco américaine qui demande
la coopération de damas ne les mentionne
que de façon allusive en tout dernier
recours et elle tomberait évidemment
très mal pour le pays au moment même où
il tente de libéraliser son économie sur
place le reportage de nos envoyés
spéciaux caroline sinsé salah a gravi à
damas le temps s'écoule avec lenteur la
vie est rythmée par les mêmes gestes
quotidiens dans cette capitale le
mélange entre tradition et modernité est
étonnant l'économie nationaliser pendant
40 ans essayent d'entrer dans le 21e
siècle
changer les habitudes comme celle de
tout payer en liquide c'est ce qu'essaye
de faire cette banque
la première banque privée ouverte en
syrie il y a un an une révolution
accompagné par une pluie de billets
placés sur les premiers comptes chèques
gérer pour la première fois par
informatique
mais il ya toujours des interdits vous
ne pouvez pas acheter des devises
étrangères sauf dans des cas très
spécifique
même si on entend un assouplissement de
la réglementation il ya également des
produits qui n'existent pas encore
il n'existe pas encore des cartes de
crédit qui ne sont pas encore autorisés
mais là aussi on certains des
changements d'ici quelques mois les
capitaux sont saoudiens et français
le marché vierge la concurrence
inexistante
malgré les risques politiques en syrie
l'opération est juteuse
la syrie a quand même environ 18
millions d'habitants est la syrie a
quand même d'importantes ressources bon
principalement du gas un peu de pétrole
et des ressources agricoles donc la
syrie a fatalement besoin de vente de
vente et d'hommes d'affaires performant
comme mouloud devenue il ya vingt ans la
patronne de dhl cette femme formée en
europe et au canada a dû s'adapter aux
méthodes syrienne il y a cinq ans
on avait plus d'interférences du
gouvernement dans la vie de tous les
jours aujourd'hui nous n'avons rien de
tout cela aujourd'hui on peut passer 100
% de notre temps à nous occuper de nos
affaires
une ouverture qui coïncide avec
l'arrivée au pouvoir de bachar al assad
la femme du président en photo avec
mouloud travail avec son mari pour
transformer son pays
mérou l'autre voudrait des réformes plus
rapides et que les femmes et plus de
droits plus de place aujourd'hui si je
regarde l'économie en syrie et les
tenues par un nombre très restreint de
personnes j'aimerais voir ce nombre se
développer j'aimerais voir plus d'hommes
et de femmes d'affaires qui se
distribuent le marché qui extensive des
réformes plus de liberté d'ouverture
vers l'étranger c'est ce que tout le
monde réclame et attend aujourd'hui en
tirer les hommes d'affaires comme la
population il en va de l'avenir et de la
survie d'un pays de plus en plus isolé
sur la scène internationale
on les appelle